I'm recording mr.
William beggs where were you born
as the banks in belfast and went on
and you know one. That's quite
a while ago. You lie and do you remember
your parents what. What did your father do
my father prefer him like
a preparing writer which is what you
know. And what did he do what was the
actual job. Oh he was. Right
and you know more work.
Yes he was ship of fire right. You call
a ship. When you don't know yet.
And how was he doing that all
his life. No i can't tell you know
and i invariably forty if you
don't know. We're did you go to
school you know one school in
belfast. At which school. Can you
remember. You know it did you
like school honor all i need
spirit and remember what you were
best at and what did you do what were
your best at what what were your best at
doing at school you think of poverty of
a free you like that and where did
you when you first go to work.
And i don't work you know. For
a week left in the right works. Yes
you know i want to ship you know.
Yes. Which if you know how no world.
And you member how old you were then
fourteen. And what do you what job did
you do. First you get an apprenticeship
straight away or did you
want to catch fire.
It catch fire catch me rev.
Wright the catcher. Yes. And then
you got an apprenticeship as
a one of make attitude i'm
to furnish it was more
a game and how long was your apprenticeship
five years. And do you remember
. The first ship that you saw launched there
and how old was you know i can't share
a number of worship of course the
ships got to leave after our launch.
Yes there were just ships
and ships. After lunch
then they had the fishery ducks. And
you got to be mayor. And you
started off as a as a catch
a boy. Yeah and after that. What
did you do next. Did you become
a copper or anything like that or you
straightaway do you. Oh he my dear boy and
seventeen. You know. Do you have to do your
father have to pay to. Do what you want
as an apprentice and phone. And if you have
to go to technical college or not. Have
you got to take it right now and again.
Yes. And how did you find the work.
Do you enjoy it or was it just
a job and what was very interesting if
you took and you know what
does. No tell you know of it.
Required. Yes. And
how long did you work as as
a pilot back when you come out of your time
i finished my time and convert hysteria
at what you would that be. And. Twenty
five twenty six. Did you come up with
that with
a bourbon at all. You know if you might
have to do if he came up in twenty six. I
think. With the with his with his cousin
dave gray and such like you cannot give
a lady yet. So yes. Do you have no crib on
the bridge was there. Yes i did say yes
. You know yet. Oh yes.
Here's i saw him there with
a bourbon out hunting give great for
a long time when you. How did you come out
here did you pay your passage a £5 or
a commode as an immigrant and did you have
a family then you know i know one here.
You came out as an immigrant and did you
have to pay part of your
passage. No i just signed it
signed on and on quite right. And you get
a job straightaway on the bridge. No
visual and start. In fact i work for
a drongo for a lord on
a ridge. Yeah yeah. Alexandra. Yes. Still
you know like you had no energy trying
to five. What was it what
was in a big sandra it was
a steel yard barn was the fabricating out
it was in alexandria. There were four
other kidding. Doing different jobs. And i
want to know if other kids how
and when did you start on the
bridge then was the art
started when when they change
and we're searching to you know
i left it on a long term rent
a bridge. So that it would that be twenty
nine. But it. Twenty eight hundred twenty
eight. I think. Because that's when dormant
long sold out there still there are
still hungry short light twenty eight 928
i left on wrong of course going wrong for
a very good to me when i worked for
some yes. So i left there to work
under it
a doorman long and alexandra.
You remember. Yes i annoyed him
he said i think i was one of
the martins no one had left
the shop gone to british
i heard about him but
i wasn't hip well. Well yeah. What
you money. You shan't mind you're
well yeah i don't know. Well these are
mine i worked on and he did he had to
straighten out and steal
a lot of ego onto the bridges
now he's here charge from work
. A journo why were got there but it
didn't go back to england. You know you're
being transferred onto the bridge
or did you go down apply for
a job there. I went down the shingle
and started who you see she mr.
Well you know. Well. All right larry.
Well. What was he like to work for
he was
a good mine was he. Was he very. Do you
require hard work or i just
leave you to it. Could you.
Everybody started their voyage of anger
especially when irish you should
strive for for
a fortnight and if you know good. Oh i
should have i've no good no shaklee
that's what you done save you know it's
gender and. Good ira. Irish good enough for
a good mind for from what i wanted. Yes
there were several hours. It used to start
off. Did you start on the on the approach
spans or on that straight on the arch on
now i can assure you pictures of the
interesting part of the village was.
You know the actual you measure i say
yes the bridge the
bearings. Yeah madrid has
a bright. All the i understand the
the bearing face. I think of
a surya pictures. I love. I've seen them
there. We can't do that on that. Can you
describe it slightly as at the base when
the bearing went straight into it you know
what did you do. I remember. Yes you were
riveted you. Yeah not bulking up you know
you know you know i would have avoided.
You know. So you were right from the
beginning of the arch all the way
always. Yes. On the same side on
a show. If you know
a straight not side right and you come over
the south pole claridge's where did you
come over the south side at all. No more
to show showed you all the north side and
i wouldn't and i showed. Who was the foreman
over there on the on the north side.
Thompson. Again sometimes and sometimes
a good man could win for money. He knew
a river or any harm. What
about the riggers with
a good director of actually staging
how was it so good. Do you move goods
couldn't be better. They
couldn't have weird thing
a better one color foul.
Khalifa and come to shove it
again. Who was rescued. Yeah
but fred he was saying we are
absolutely. Food for the
fall after he fell.
There was nothing to hide. Was there anything
to hold on my was there and you know
you just sit on the
stage you know i've got
a real one on shane shane but there
was nothing for us to hold onto for
. Words where we did
shove was used words you
you couldn't buy
a forfeit unless you were
struggling and fell off.
And it was the job
a different judge you've done
before. Now i don't know. You
seem to like
a very well and certainly ignorant
and i could time for them
because
a very good company were fine with that
before the printer after before adverts
and all the steel was it that you working
on on the arch was that all from england
dollar gold wrong wrong with no. Look for
dome long treatment you want very should
be in the railways you will in the
stations. You made friends realise you
wouldn't find any strong student no show.
Honey i would shoot around the city. Oh
no i understand that. Yes but i mean you
walk into the railway station with you
there and you look at that and you'll see
dawn and
a lot. I care for it because when you
tour before you sure don't. Yeah yeah.
So you said you went right through from
the from the arch to the start to the
finish work through it and dave
great was your was your cook who
dave grey give greater invite to
come. And it was your holder or take
a crew member. A general way you
found him because you're into force.
Now haven't seen him since you
had him all the way through was
a hold up did him very well all the way
through and do i do you your moron know
a bit of alright. And the riveting
the tightness of the rivets with the duty
to the inspectors come round and and back
to inspect the rear tested them. What
happened if they were if they were not not
tied to the first like it might come to
come march and how did you cut them out
credit right shin. Up so i've got
to yeah of course
a cup and function of
punch them through and
what sort of percentage do you reckon that
you had to come up you know how many did
you lost to come out or just
a few my aunt myra i was good.
You know and i always always had
a good test. In fact. Jimmy she was it was
inspected. And i was taken
from one chord back.
A nervous well-marked coach. And
i said to communication you
took
a more difficult drop. She was straight
on the knee and he had no want to
go on ojha will take this one.
Nash one and that one. When you take
a much reflection. Sure. Watching
a fairer. John not just say it's
good you have an easy of the
year. Did you always have to read it down
or did you sometimes have to read it on
an
e sometimes under the shame on knees
as very hard on top. Fret and top just
feet on the bottom and it was
a very hard work really think
it would be if you were under
a river if you were pretty
right. You got you know it's
gone. Red i need any of the
government me. Yeah so hard work
for
a long time. You know how many other of us
would you put in and the day we want one
. Do you think there was
very easy. We just went
naturally along. Didn't do anything. And i
didn't have only i learned i
drew. And when you were you.
Can you wonder how well clary have well
all the time. Yes you do see much of
laurence ennis the director told whom
laurence ennis did you see much of him at all
. Laurie lawrence ennis the director. If
you see anything of him you know i didn't
see much of him. What about dr.
Redfield if you see
anything of him to induct
a brush you know jim what was he doing
just red checking i think you know he is
it very very because he won
a bridge to be built. Yes yes and it was
a shameless bridge over
time a contract to build
a no bridge before the crash some ten had
a bridge exactly the same design
shorter mission our village
very much different than the design and i
said the design was very much different
in which it was a shame of
a shooting over the cambridge. You
know network for door for dong long
to find
a very judge you know his own. Not to do
you know we just owned it rain. There
it will cambridge just to shame if
you go to scrap an i've been over
there and i've seen the time but for the
time bridge has the top and bottom caught
me at the bearings. Whereas
a 300 ft difference here to the bridge here
has got you know in post about 300 feet
long. I would have bridge where one over
and on the time it's got at the end of the
post the top court in the bottom court
meet at the parent they come together at
a point to bury you. And the new
castle bridge. Oh i shot from
a tree and if you look something similar
that way but it's actually when you when
you work it out. It's a i saw
a human gene. As an arch bridge but the
top caught on the bottom caught me at the
bearings either side and the new muscle
bridge. Oh i thought russian regime in fact
. I thought of russia on the train. Well
in actual fact that he was consulting
engineer on both yes that's true.
When you were you were here
you never worked in the workshops at all.
Did you ever go to work never manage to
give
a go in the workshops. I want soon. But
where did you live when you worked on the
bridge that question. You
know i can't i'm sure.
There was with don the north side. No i
didn't live don't now talk of love
or if more never loved you more.
You can't remember where you lived in our
country and one. How did you get to get
to work then. Oh yes i remember
when forever on the tram
right down to circular quay.
Yes that's right. It's
a fair distance not unless it's not that
far in the tram go. And we do get married
during the time you were on the bridge at
my age i don't. Lovely wife she died. So
and you live with your daughter that ice
age or they're all right when you when you
can you ever how much you got paid
a week on the bridge. I
would. You know name guinea
. Pretty good was a pretty good money was
a good one and we remember the
boilermakers union. Yes i'm still in
a very rigorous connect it was from
there. Showed me the newspaper but
up for only thing i hear from. You did
you know charlie brown in those days it
was in the union. You know do
you know charlie veron until
a matter of fairness. Jamie on the bridge.
Can you remember any of the other
boilermakers you worked
worked with on the reg
a long time ago. You know i wouldn't have
money i mean if they knew. Charlie hayes
and i do
a shot of her i knew more no bridge
you know i showed you know we
did you know you kelly. Did you. But kelly
a fellow actor grew flesh.
When he fell irish or
very next day. Well at least they
read it until the rigors and
improved where kelly was because
you couldn't fall off when
i got down there was
the bridges there were
ordinary where they had weird
or even. We couldn't for
you have any other accidents did you get
involved in any accidents or near misses
and would involve them ahead of them
did you hear of. Different ones fail.
You wouldn't know one thing more
only sean fell for you didn't know
campbell or you know you know campbell
or addison. I don't know what
actually he was a he was
a he was he was about to make as assistant
working with stan london on he was
belting up. Yes i knew
when he found he was on
a course i me falling
on spent so long. Fun
and you know it's like
a fund you know stand up like you got
a wife to be
a great around today and
a full shot across of course. Yes it was
a nasty business that there was there was
a few was one and woods as well who was
over on the approach spans before that i
don't cite one name woods. I had
a bad word for norm and i was
a rigger on that side to us and where
you are working. We were on the
top court about
a court i don't know tom ford. I think sorry
all the time i run the bottom cord. I
started it and leaves it up.
And when the arch joined we
were up there. I told them a cup cord.
We got there that night or waited
a day. So you know day
to day. Yes i remember
that day work then. There's
a first time that you wear the cross. I
mean when was the first time you went
across. Oh we want
a cute even when i see the
plank over change of course we
run across no again it is immature and
high on and i showed up. I shall say once
you joined up. Yeah. Do you
remember who went across
first. Oh yeah for bradfield
you know i've heard all sorts of stories
you know i had one story whereby there was
a wreck and the apprentices from the workshop
climbed the cranes and went over the
top there that way. That's one thing you
couldn't do. That's why i think they
couldn't do you say you know couldn't do
a lot of close to that credit
ever probably stop putting you
know he door shut and they reckon if they
claim that you on one from one train to
the other one in the lunch.
That's not their regular
here and there and they were princes in
the workshop. I reckon they clung to the
lunch. Below and then they got onto the
grandfather and he put them alongside so
they could do it but it only i
think you think it's allowed.
And after they joined was it was it was
easier walking around after that. No i
wasn't much yeah you know on the
absent joint we all work and
yeah and you didn't try to
go course. Mary quote him
a chair i walk and want to go yet.
Do you remember when before it
joined whether the the courts used to
shake as the as the crane was moving
a told you feel that now i
know there was never an
a movement and now. In fact that the trend
there i'm sure it was before
much. From the east or west on
i know i showed one because it gives
a song much. Kiloton watcher of the world.
You didn't feel it moving at all without
when the crane was working and lifting
things you know never move and when you when
they got close together and you can see
that they did see that they move you member
that whenever they have several people said
that when they got close together. The
two halves got close together that they
could see that they were swaying past each
other. Straight and swaying in relation
to each other. The two you know for
a you know there's no where
the cueball held. I had
qq from voice showed she
was killed every where
generals were actually in the ground. Yes
i understand and they held average. Yes.
Their nose gear always had the ability
. No want to. It will
just shrink east or west
made. No on the hills like
them. No cordon around
them but several people said that without
the temperature of the sun on one side
compared to the other used to make the
two halves sometimes move in relation to
each other. You wouldn't feel it but you
could see that time. If you had no no
affect on. On to your tour
because and showed the chord
some longer. Yes and they
control it. Actually
if they were true i think
you know it. Surely he
. The. Did you see the inspectors
go inside the court and measure the
stresses and side that there was some
terra boy and i'm one come up with
a northern ireland. No reference
to the chord. And that's
a little thing really.
Did you. Did you ever remember any
inspectors at all. You were part of your own
one or any of the other people. I remember
hillary care she would. Yeah and
factor. He inspected i work
traitor. If it referred to him and
you think that's what ties are on
that job and any others over there
just seems no teeter on the bridge an
ordinary job. Course on the
ship but to return to gestured
more friday on
a boat in the hot hour no good you shall.
And when you were. When
you were up to go up
a morning. Did you take your lunch with
your did you come down the last time. What
about toilet arrangements up there were
there anything like that up there. In which
was any ties arrangements up the top and
you and he toilet arrangements up the top
. You know i think were all good growing
everyone wanted to go to turkey. Did you
know i know it was it was there any changing
rooms down below where you could hang
it in such low. Hang the cruel
michoud on which side on
a north side was any washing
facilities. You know do i think well i
always try and i got really sick to
actually fish. You know. I fish and work at
dirty. Did you ever scare you
up there with the wind. We are
scared with the wind up there. Yes around
chump change was pretty nasty. When what
it was to know you were we kept
law. You know i think yes. Where.
What about when it was wet wet we had
to run the risk of slip and. I had
understood. On my feet.
What were they made of.